can you speak to some uh recent high
profile
divorces
uh like the most recent I saw is Kevin
Costner yeah Kevin Costner is a great um
I mean I don't know him I'm not involved
in the case by the way Yellowstone's
just so great oh it's so good right and
I hope Matthew McConaughey who I've
gotten to know I hope I hope he does one
of the one of these shows is Yellowstone
or anything else he's just he born for
the role Frank yeah but anyway he'd be
amazing in that yeah your conversation
with him was a great one the Kevin
Costner divorce is interesting because
Kevin Costner had one of the most
expensive
from a district of award perspective
like he he gave a huge payout to his
first wife
um and then this time he had a prenup so
it's actually it's a very public showing
of the fact that once bitten twice shy
like he had a very public divorce that
cost him a lot of Assets in terms of the
division of assets and now it appears by
all acknowledged reports that he had a
prenuptial agreement that was well
crafted and enforceable and you know
he's he's
um the argument now is over
what is child support what is spousal
support what's covered in the prenup and
what isn't so it seems like the prenup
worked actually the prenup worked you
know and Kevin Costner's career which
has always been a steady career
I don't know that in the like Hollywood
stock market that people would have bet
on Yellowstone like I don't I think you
would have said hey the best years of
that guy's career were behind him you
know how do you get better than Dances
with Wolves and Robin Hood and like all
these big big The Bodyguard yeah and
then Yellowstone and it's like holy cow
did he knock that out of the park and
he's Central to it I mean he knocked the
skin off the ball so I think that's why
prenups are important you don't know
what your career is going to do you
don't know where it's going to go and so
he saved himself a lot of money he also
has a great lawyer he has Laura wasser
Laura wasser's you know La you know just
a top professional brilliant lawyer
um even tempered but intense in the
courtroom and just a smart smart human
being the thing I liked just you know I
haven't been following it but I saw a
few comments he's made in
he like refused to comment negatively
about his spouse and she's just smart
but like the way he said it it wasn't
lawyer advice it's good lawyer advice
probably but he said it from the heart
which I always like I like seeing that
yeah like where he he refuses even the
drama even the public nature of it to
throwing Jabs or well Laura his lawyer
is actually notorious for like not
speaking to the Press about cases in an
extended way and that's smart move like
I don't speak about pending cases I'm
involved in
um publicly and I discourage my clients
from doing so I can't always stop them
but but I discourage them from doing so
I I don't think there's any good to come
of it there are lawyers who try to try
things in the court of public opinion
um I think there is a
to take it to the broader principle you
just brought up I I think there is a lot
of value in talking about your ex in a
favorable way
I have to say
when I first got divorced many years ago
I went on on a date with a young woman
it's one of my first dates as a divorced
man
and she was a divorced woman
she's a beautiful woman
and we were having dinner and it was
going quite well and it was one of those
things where I was like oh I definitely
want to see this girl again
and I said something about oh you know
there's going to be this thing at this
Museum we should go and she's like oh
yeah that'd be a lot of fun and I'm like
yeah we should definitely you know maybe
the next thing we do together and she
was like yeah we should go next weekend
like the kids are with the so we
can go and I just it was like you could
hear that record scratch like you know I
just went oh yeah no this isn't good
like I'm not you're referring to the
father of your kids is it the
like we're like we're we're already I'm
walking into something here that I don't
know that I want to be involved in
Matthew McConaughey before he was
married
you know if you look at his history he
dated some of the most beautiful women
in Hollywood in their Prime
and none of them
ever talked bad about him in the Press
they all were like oh my God he's such a
great guy such great and I always
wondered like how do you he got out of
all of those relationships without a
without a scratch on him and when you'd
watch an interview with him
they would say like so you you know you
dated Penelope Cruz and he'd go
Penelope that's just that's just a
special lady that is just a what a what
a special lady she's just a wonderful
what a wonderful woman are just so
blessed to have the time with her what a
beautiful wonderful woman and and I
would think to myself I'm like I'm like
you're a genius like he's a genius
because like it it he never came off as
Petty spiteful bitter any of that he
just came off as like just dignified
strong smart self-assured and like it
left
you know it left like it it left the the
viewer
with the impression that like when he
was looking off and specifically like
he's probably like just thinking about
some wonderful time he had with her and
you think to yourself like God that guy
like he just became cooler and cooler
whereas if he got into like the whole
you know oh yeah that was ugly and then
you know this happened and that like
nobody wants to hear it it's awful the
funny thing about him just having to
interact with a little bunch I don't
think he's in the he's in the Rogan
school of thought I think that I don't
see him ever having a fight
now his parents were as he as he's
spoken about a bunch non-stop fighting
it got divorced and remarried and yeah
just insane and they were volatile yeah
very he seems maybe you kind of uh it
depend on swinging the other way he just
seems cool as a cucumber like always
just lets it roll off yeah but you know
even if it's
internally yeah not rolling off
there is value
in just Rising above it in your
discourse
that's true yes like like you lie to
your children like people say to me all
the time clients they're like
you know why did you tell your child
that Dad had an affair well I'm not
gonna lie to my kids
you yes you are you lie to your
kids all the time yeah Mommy are you
gonna die someday yes babe I'm gonna die
and daddy's gonna die and then someday
the Earth's gonna hurl into the Sun and
we're all gonna die sweet dreams like
that's not you lie to your kids all the
time you know what's wrong with me we
don't know what's wrong with you we're
gonna take you to the doctor and
hopefully it's nothing serious and you
won't die like you lie your kids all the
time you tell them that Santa Claus
exists when he does whatever
so so to say I'm not gonna lie to my
kids you lie to your kids all the time
you don't like your husband that's okay
you don't like your ex-husband but it's
their father so just grin you know Oh
Daddy took me to meet his new girlfriend
Kiki oh that's nice you guys have a good
time good all that's yeah and she helped
me do my hair and she did my makeup
listen I'm sure that's burning you
inside
but you go oh that's great because why
you love you kids well that's what I
mean again makani has a as a way about
him with that he's like he basically
says never lie but a little is
okay sure sure